نعم
[موسيقى]
حرب بدات في الرابع والعشرين من شباط
فبراير عام 2022
[موسيقى]
بلغت خسائر الجيش الروسي فيها حتى اللحظه
200 الف بين قتيل وجريح
[موسيقى]
ولجا بسببها نحو 8 ملايين اوكراني الى عده
دول في اوروبا ومع ذلك ما يزال هناك بحسب
مراقبين امر وحيد شبه مؤكد عجز الطرفين عن
حسم المعركه وهو ما قد يستمر اسابيع او
شهورا وربما سنوات
[موسيقى]
فما ابرز مسارات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
المسار الاول التوصل الى تسويه مشتركه
وفق هذا السيناريو تنتهي الحرب بتقسيم
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بين موسكو الامر الذي
يعني الابقاء على الوضع الراهن من سيطره
موسكو على بعض الاراضي الاوكرانيه مع
تطبيق وقف لاطلاق النار
وتنقسم اوكرانيا الى حكومتين احداها تابعه
للحكم الروسي واخرى تابعه بضمانات امريكيه
وغربيه
السيناريو المطروح يتوقعه بعض المراقبين
لاسباب عده ويشيرون في هذا الصدد الى
سابقه تاريخيه حين غزت القوات السوفياتيه
فنلندا عام
1939 فيما عرف بحرب الشتاء حينها اضطرت
فنلندا الى قبول وقف اطلاق النار وتوقيع
معاهده سلام تنازلت بموجبها عن تسعه
بالمئه من اراضيها للسوفيات بعد عجزها عن
استرداد جزرها المحتله في المقابل يستبعد
خبراء هذا السيناريو لاسباب تتعلق برفض
كييف للحل المطروح وخصوصا مع اشتراط
حكومتها انسحاب القوات الروسيه للدخول في
مفاوضات
المسار الثاني سقوط اوكرانيا كامله
[موسيقى]
يرى مؤيد هذا السيناريو ان اوكرانيا تخوض
حربا وجوديه مع روسيا وهو ما يدفع جيشها
الى مقاومه العتاد الروسي بكل ما اوتي من
قوه لكن ذلك لا يلغي في نظرهم اثر الدعم
الغربي في ثبات اوكرانيا واستمرار
مقاومتها واذا تقلص هذا الدعم او توقف
فستكون كيف عرضه لخساره جميع اراضيها في
مده وجيزه وخصوصا في ظل التفوق العسكري
لروسيا وهو الامر الذي يزيد تصميم موسكو
على خوض الحرب على الرغم من الخسائر
الكبيره التي كبدتها
المسار الثالث استمرار الحرب سنوات طويله
[موسيقى]
سيناريو ترجحه الاستخبارات الامريكيه التي
ترى ان الحرب بين موسكو هي حرب استنزاف قد
تستمر وان من الصعب على اي من طرفي النزاع
حسم القتال فيها لصالحه وخصوصا مع السياسه
التي انتهجتها في الحرب والتي تمثلت في
مساعده اوكرانيا للحيلوله دون سقوطها بيد
الروس وتجنب مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا قد
تضطر فيها الى استخدام ترسانتها النوويه
[موسيقى]
المسار الرابع خساره روسيا وانهيارها
عسكريا
بحسب مؤيدي هذا المسار اصبحت الحرب عبئا
كبيرا على روسيا ولم تعد كما كان يتصور
القاده الروس مغامره عسكريه سريعه ولا
سيما بعد ان فاقت خسائر الجيش الروسي
توقعات الرئيس بوتين حين اصدر قرار الغزو
وبسبب الحرب تعاني موسكو عزله دوليه
وعقوبات اقتصاديه كبيره اثرت تاثيرا كبيرا
في الاوضاع المعيشيه للروس وارتفعت
الاصوات في الداخل الروسي المطالب بانهاء
الحرب وخصوصا بعد تجنيد المدنيين والزج
بهم في المعارك هذه العوامل تضغط على
القياده الروسيه وقد تجبرها على انهاء
الحرب عندها سيكون الرئيس بوتين قد رسم
نهايه حكمه بيده اذ ان بقائه في السلطه
صار رهن الحرب المصيريه